this is lucy james reading for reviewer
alex [ __ ] in gran turismo 7 the latest
entry in the playstation's top flight
race series perfection isn't only famed
producer kazunori yamauchi's aim it
swiftly becomes yours it's been a
quarter of a century since the real
driving simulator that got petrol heads
obsessed with lap times on the ps1
released and it hasn't evolved massively
for better and for worse it's strangely
familiar but it plays as close to
driving a real car as you can get on a
console and draws you in with challenges
physics and luscious visuals
gran turismo's goal to be the best
looking driving sim out there hasn't
been dropped there are two display modes
to choose from escapes mode and frame
rate mode on a ps5 connected to a 4k tv
with ray tracing enabled escapes mode
becomes a visual treat for snap happy
players and fans of custom creations
everything looks smooth enough that
you'll want to run your fingers across
the glistening paint jobs however when
you're racing you'll want to have frame
rate mode switched on this keeps the
game at a steady 60 frames per second
but does lose some visual flair
how much you'll care about that may be
limited as when you're racing you'll
likely only have eyes for the car in
front not how accurate the reflection of
the advertisements your blitzing past is
on the hood
even without raytracing the hyper
detailed in-car view shows bits of the
dashboard reflected in the windshield
drawing your eye it can be a bit
distracting but that's how real cars
work
gran turismo 7's 420 plus car models are
staggering not a switch out of place nor
an incorrect line to my experienced eyes
if you're into staring at cars you
really can't go wrong sniffing around
brand central the in-game location where
you buy the majority of gt7s cars it's
here you'll notice something a bit
strange though while each model is
impressive many are a little on the old
side the tesla model s for example is
the original pre-facelift car why have
that when there's a fresh-faced plaid
model on sale now
how come the most up-to-date road-going
mclaren you can buy in the game the 650s
went out of production half a decade ago
the cars that are there look incredible
but the vast majority are out of date
some of the older cars are there for
good reason a classic mustang is always
a great time and belongs in gran turismo
for the sake of being awesome and saving
credits to afford a legendary aston
martin is an achievement to be
celebrated so it's not all dude wears my
car
gt7 has a charming story mode of sorts
the cafe it's here players will be
steadily introduced to all the joys the
game has to offer via luca the cafe's
friendly owner he provides you with menu
books that set specific challenges which
unlock tracks features or cars to
bolster your collection and collect a
level which in turn increases as you
collect cars and gains you more rewards
unless the challenge is to go to a
specific place like the amusingly named
understeer tuning shop to fettle your
car or gt auto for a new wing chances
are you'll find yourself in a race to
win a car of some sort
in an attempt to humanize gran turismo
polyphony's given luca a cast of friends
sarah guides you around the gt world
acting as something of a proxy car
designers will appear at the cafe to
tell you all about how great your car is
gt world tour races act as instructors
on licensed tests adding smiles to what
used to be a fairly robotic process
they're all represented as faces in
disks with text underneath unfortunately
the scripts they deliver go from a bit
clunky to i can smell the cheese from
here players will amass the kind of car
collection a millionaire would be proud
of fairly quickly but places to drive
those cars can take a while longer to
roll out because there are fewer tracks
than cars however this ultimately is not
a bad thing the tracks take a while to
learn anyway because of this you never
feel rushed to pick up too many things
too quickly though you don't get to
spend too much time with your motors
before moving on to the next set
sometimes you'll be rewarded with a
roulette ticket these seem like a neat
idea but the promise of a shiny new car
or a huge stack of credits seemed in my
case at least to be a little more than
dangled carrots to hook you the actual
prizes won being low value
races go the usual gran turismo away you
start at the back and fight your way to
the front races have a recommended pp or
performance point rating to let you know
how competitive your car needs to be by
sending whichever car you've chosen to
race to understeer and buying choice
toys you can comically overpower your
ride and pick off most of the field on
the first lap like gt games of old the
pack at the rear is easy to take a small
gap leads you to another set after
another gap you'll encounter the front
runners before having a mildly troubling
fight for first why gran turismo insists
on starting you at the back of the pack
for each race is baffling but for a
one-off race it's understandable for the
occasional championships where you win
or plays highly in a previous race that
aside the racing is still fun ai
competitors drive defensively and
occasionally make mistakes each race
does feel similar and occasionally
rubber bandy but there's enough
challenge in there to make you return
for more license tests are back and are
addictive albeit occasionally
frustrating little tasks that teach you
the game's physics model the way gran
turismo handles is as you'd hope after a
quarter of a century of refinement bang
on barrel into corners with the throttle
wide open and you'll understeer lift off
mid-corner and the rear will swing round
depending on how many of the game's
myriad modifications from understeer or
gt auto you've applied it'll behave
differently but within the rules of
gt7's physics the same goes for
increment conditions not all circuits
can have dynamic weather but those that
can are a different broader kind of fun
to play on you'll first find your super
slick race tires an expensive investment
but a good way to up performance points
fast are now useless you'll then either
learn how to control a slide at speed or
where the retry button is the track will
dry eventually your palms
maybe not
night driving's a blast as are the
astronomically accurate starscapes that
keep the sky bright
while racing and collecting are the main
focus you'd be a fool to miss out on
missions these include a variety of
different driving challenges such as
slip streaming for speed drag racing or
overtaking challenging opponents in a
short slot of track like license tests
they can be frustrating but you'll keep
coming back for more similarly the music
rally function is a neat distraction
from the main game drive quick enough to
music so you don't run out of beats you
start with a set amount of beats that
decrease with each well beat of the song
you're listening to drive quick enough
and you'll pick more up via gates on the
track run out and it's game over finish
the whole song and you've won not a
reason to buy it outright but
entertaining if you want something
different there's still no obvious
damage to cars though yamauchi and the
polyphony team want racing clean so cars
don't need to get damaged but it's 2022
if i have a prang the game should know
about it considering the level of detail
that's gone into the rest of the game it
seems like something of a cop-out to not
have any evidence of a crash even
cosmetic another thing that hasn't leapt
to the next gen is the sound 3d audio
tech means you can hear more but what
you hear isn't edge of your seat
thrilling there are plenty of places to
race in gt7 some based on real locations
some exclusive to the game with 90
layouts and over 34 tracks to earn and
explore you shouldn't find yourself
bored each track comes with its own
challenges not only in layout but in
environmental changes as well while
you'll be concentrating on a race it's a
lot more exciting when the sun's out and
the rains at bay as having more grip
tends to make winning races easier
at the time of review gt7's online mode
casual ranked or the meeting spaces
wasn't available but if polyphony's
carrying over the gt sport system we've
little to worry about all your gt sport
data will be transferred though sadly
not your garage as with gt sport you
need to have a constant internet
connection for most of the game to work
and save this says polyphony is to curb
cheating still we'll sink some time into
the online modes and update this review
to reflect our experiences
gran turismo 7 isn't a departure but
rather a newer shinier gt game its
physics model is accurate and while the
racing can be formulaic it's always a
giggle the attempt at humanity is a
little bit cringy the lack of up-to-date
cars seems like an open goal mist and
the game may not have changed
drastically but that's not the worst
thing in the world there are medals to
claim cars to collect and people on the
internet to embarrass around goodwood
the ring or well anywhere really
playstation petrol heads are in for a
good time
[Music]
you